j'ai encore passé un vendredi soir
d'exception grâce à ses 8 j'ai trouvé
vraiment super le prime de brocante qui
avait vendredi soir mais non c'était
patrick sabatier justement parce que
sabatier c'était la galère donc devant
la librairie pardon c'était la première
devant andy vérité palmas l'unisson
sabatier reconnaître la vérité dans
cette affaire de tf1 alors quand on voit
le logo de l'émission vous voyez là on
se dit ouah on va avoir un programme
dans l'ambiance new york série alors
qu'en fait c'était plus combien sucy en
brie
apparaît alors on a appris des choses
incroyables sur pda il ya un scoop qui
m'a totalement chamboulé attention vous
allez être choqué s'il est vraiment
c'est vrai voici le laurier de l'info
tellement capital que si tu la connais
pas tu as raté ta vie
très pauvre d'abord vous mangez une
madeleine tous les matins
[Applaudissements]
c'est papa malick ba s'est sorti d'un
conte qui me dit je crois que je vais
faire alors justement regard des gels
alerte mort mais si regardez elle est là
voilà comment j'aimerais que tous les
matins il n'a pas osé l'annoncé mais il
n'ya pas que les journalistes français
quant aux prix cette info capitale tous
les jt du monde entier ont parlé du
madeleine gates regardez lombard qui
nous regardent également qu'il regarde
ce soir ya soit il ya crime à la crème
bien sûr comme ça on sait qu'elle est n
1 h 30 patrick sabatier nombreuses bien
sûr alors qu'à la fin qu'elle a fait
l'ena parrot faire la publicité pour des
marques sont et c'est quand il y en a
invité cas qui porte une marque on met
un scotch dessus parce que je sais de
marque aussi donc du ruban adhésif
d'accord et d'un an vendredi vérité il y
avait tellement pas de budget ruban
adhésif que je décède durant m lorée de
l'émission qui a cru qu'en cachant de
lettre personnelle et reconnaître ce
journal
[Musique]
évidemment on a caché le titre mais
c'est vous avez droit colette
voici la une d'un grand quotidien du
matin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
expo c'est pas possible on à le remplir
la publicité ou la presse ça allait mais
si énorme ça du tout noir à ses rôles où
tout le monde a vu que c'est le figaro
heureusement vous être rude
alors vendredi à des moments où je me
croyais revenu en 88 quand j'avais la
coiffure de macgyver s'il ya très
longtemps
on va dire que le rythme de l'émission
était posée quand quelqu'un commencer
une phrase tu avais le temps d'aller
pisser quand tu revenais avec jean pas
fini sa phrase
mais bon c'est normal que la moyenne
d'âge des intervenants étaient calmes de
98 alors j'ai décidé d'euros mais non
moi j'en ai marre je suis à deux doigts
d'arrêter la gdc de remettre avant on
dit vérité le laurier de l'émission il y
avait que des gens qui étaient en classe
avec napoléon et isabelle morini bosc
[Musique]
tellement prier que je ne rentrais pas
dans sa vie c'est vrai que c'est une
rolls oui vous collectionnez les simples
du monde
oui alors 607 semble un peu partout en
avantage quand on a deux personnes d'âge
mûr c'est que niveau audition c'est fut
trop ça alors quand le dj balance on
sait pas pourquoi le dernier quart is
personne n'entend alors si je marque je
le marque ce qui pousse à laurent
boillot l'action sur le terrain
hier le quai des rêves c'est vrai c'est
vraiment parti pour sébastien bastian va
être pendant la diffusion il ya à
laâyoune qui est parti et moi je vois là
tu te tais de patrick savatier et croyez
qu'avec des zincs c'était quoi ces lois
doivent encore c'est j'adore avc moi
j'ai bien aimé moi aussi j'ai beaucoup
aimé y regarder en loges ce que j'arrête
c'était juste avant balance compost
d'ailleurs on va parler de danse tout de
suite ça y est il est encore à sa
balance tant poste l'émission dont le
thème était l'amour vrai et il y avait
des stars dans votre émission cyril
parce que ben oui avec kad et olivier
oui si si je vous assure regarder alors
ça c'était gilles c'était gilles et avec
sa femme n'est franchement on dirait
olivier baroux kad charybde en quelques
instants alors rebondi vous receviez
nilsen qui a raconté qu'il avait séduit
une de ses profs est vrai que j'adore
zoomer sur vos têtes pendant les
séquences vous savez la mort ça je faire
des gifs un jour aux promis on va dire
que nielsen et adobe charmant mais il
est comme moi on va pas le classer dans
la catégorie des beaux gosses kouassi et
charmant mais pas beau gosse à un moment
il vous dit quelque chose
et immédiatement j'ai tenu à vous
remettre le laurier du gars qui a du mal
à cacher qu'il n'est pas convaincu par
ce qu'on lui raconte
on est jeune on aime bien séduire et ça
c'est un mec ou rodez faut juste eu à
constructeur
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien on me le sait bien sûr
holloway nissen a oui ou non il était
mignon voulez on peu l'on peut en voir
la séquence dans son ensemble sur voila
c'est en somme je suis tout seul
[Musique]
on est jeune on aime bien séduire et ça
c'est un mec plus gros défaut je suis à
constructeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà chesnais s'est récemment dit que
entre les chroniqueurs de ballons et se
touche pas à mon poste il ya un énorme
écart
bon un écart de salaire ça c'est sûr
mais on dit que ceux de ballons ce
propos sont beaucoup plus sérieux et
bien est-ce que je vous montre et ce
sera terminé je pense qu'après avoir vu
ça vous allez remonter les bretelles de
tout le monde il le faut aussi le
laurier de l'émission les chroniqueurs
sont payés pour envoyer des sms pas et
les des trophées là je vais défoncer
nature à saturer les débloquer
c'est presque universel au cas où aucune
civilisation qui nous avons entendu les
bruits de sms regarder quelqu'un et
c'est discrètement d'envoyer des textos
de noix
or la question c'est qui le coupable le
être humain est susceptible avec son
temps d'isère il travaille il s'agit
d'eric revel il va par des sanctions en
michel mr aurait été renvoyé chez lui
pour beaucoup moins que ça leur a même
cyril que si vous renvoyez plus monde
ceux qui envoient des sms
franchement vous allez retrouver tout
seul surtout à cause et tout ça je vous
allez voir en même temps c'est plus
rentable mais scandaleux alors le pompon
revient à gâteau proulx qui elle voue
provoque son recul j'aime bien aucun
souci regardez-moi ça si je suis avec
mon amoureux et que je ressens pas de
désir pour lui je peux pas l'envisager
amoureusement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle avait une urgence médicale
mais attention je l'avais remarqué vous
inquiétez nisme est ce que je vous ai
pas fait des réprimandes après
l'émission
vous m'avez tirer les oreilles non à
tout le monde oui mais parce que leurs
membres n'ont jamais su ce que je suis
et mon petit préféré arrêter oui mais
fall est plus tendres alors on en
affirmant à jean et moi même devenue
cette fois on a la chance d'accueillir
pour la première fois celui que le nom
le plus extraordinaire de l'histoire de
la télévision
mohamed c'est le cousin de steven
mouloud génial qu'à nos malheurs et vous
allez dans ses modes marvin kader ben
moctar ben moctar alors il revient du
même centre de formation que moi c'est
que de la télé présentée par la lady
gaga berbère illégalement dans balances
ton post en fait comme au foot on dit
souvent il mange à tous les ateliers et
y est partout le mec je suis très étonné
qu'il soit avec nous ce soir parce qu'il
était très à 100 avec vous vendredi dans
les insolents selon reza regardez-moi ça
aussi le laurier du chroniqueur qui se
permet de rembarrer son boss mais cas
quand même une promotion
lors d'un rapport sexuel des hormones
circulent dans notre sens permettant de
se sentir mieux dans notre tête
lorsqu'on ne fait plus l'amour le manque
se fait donc ressentir
il ya un système immunitaire fragilisé
c'est vrai un dhimmi mohamed oumar été
cité une bêtise je n'ai pas compté dans
le docteur mais si sa belle mère peut
venir chercher
non
alors pendant 10 ans on n'en fait pas
trop rigide bondi soir la star de
balances ton post est incertain mais je
dis ah oui quand on est là il amer voici
là dehors j'ai regardé à win avait agi
de manière à l'armée mais je dis c'est
un phénomène un phénomène aussi été
magnifique on va dire que ça on aime
beaucoup mais la culture et mais je dis
c'est un petit peu comme jean mas
castadi la fidélité à la même chose ça
vaut d'exemple ça va faire plaisir à sa
une de ces femmes
non j'ai décidé de remettre année jeudi
le laurier du gars qui étaient censés
participer aux anges
11 mais qui s'est retrouvée dans
balances ton pote
[Musique]
voilà ça va c'est pas miss cougar c'est
bon et éric nolin vous voulez des
enfants plus tard d'henry et vous croyez
que me suis va pouvoir vous en donner
oui il a 53 ans n'est pas non plus pelé
toi toi déjà toi même avant de vouloir
plaire aux autres exacto popopo en une
émission il est passé de jessica des
marseillais à nietzsche je suis liberté
c'est ce que ces libertés
oui vous avez partagé dans les saunas is
maintenant c'est pas simplement un peu
con mais je dis
là ils vont finir écrit je trouve que
vous avez passé une soirée difficile
vendredi
pourquoi pas ça parce qu'en fait pas
parce que par rapport à andy vérité et
non pas du tout je prends pas de ça mais
des fois on avait l'impression que
quelqu'un s'était amusé à mettre de
fausses infos dans vos fiches
ouais je vous assure alors aussi le
laurier de l'animateur qui a passé une
soirée aussi difficile que si regarder
une émission de bernard montiel
teague et bondy soir cyril la preuve
vous poser des questions à la bruno
guillon miss cougar c'est quoi c'est en
fait c'est la miss cougar même votre
élocution on aurait dit un mix entre
celle de jean michel mr et de benjamin
castaldi
vous n'êtes jamais vu vous êtes vous
êtes cousin mais son sens nouveau sans
vous êtes vous avez vous donner une info
sur une invitée c'était pas la peine
j'habite ce blog et ancien coach en
séduction vous êtes absolument géniaux
vous accorde alors rapidement le même
nom de famille comme on n'a pas le même
nom vous êtes fait insulter très bien
notamment est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter non familier et votre histoire
est tombée amoureuse du père de votre
marque et heureusement quand vous partez
dans l'explication trop compliqué à
gâteau qu'on était là pour vous aider
cyril est le fils du frère de la mère de
michaela on l'a fait sans cause à voix
basse et son cousin
merci
[Applaudissements]